despite india recording its highest
number of coronavirus cases since the
pandemic began
tens of millions of people turned out to
cast their ballot on tuesday
polling is being held over eight days in
west bengal three days in
assam but only on tuesday in tamilnadu
kerala and puducherry
the election is the first in assam since
the bjp government carried out a
controversial register of citizens
a campaign it said was meant to check
illegal immigration from neighbouring
bangladesh
nearly 2 million of the state's 35
million population were left off the
list
including hakimuddin ali he cast his
vote anyway
as he waits to appeal against his
exclusion
i have voted today and for this reason i
am very happy because i am a citizen of
india after they get the votes and form
the government they harass us
if they keep us out it will hurt us
the bjp has avoided talking about its
register of citizens and an equally
unpopular law which fast tracks
citizenship to minorities from
neighboring countries but excludes
muslims
it's focused instead on infrastructure
projects and development but many voters
aren't convinced
there's unemployment everywhere the
youth don't have any jobs and they roam
around aimlessly so what will we do
all of the states holding on tuesday are
outside the bjp's
hindi speaking base in northern and
central india it has never been in power
in kerala
or india's fourth most popular state
west bengal
the campaign and voting there has been
marred by violence between workers of
the bjp
and the ruling trinimu congress led by
mamtha banerjee
it's very very important for bjp they
think that if they can win
west bengal they will be able to convey
to people at large
that coronavirus has a very limited
impact
the government has handled very well the
issues of
joblessness of unemployment all these
things have been
by and large taking good care by the
government which is strong at the moment
over the past seven years the bjp has
swept victory in two general elections
but done poorly in states where regional
parties
are more powerful with these latest
elections it's trying to change that
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi